I swear we're not trying to be scared
hi I'm Johnny the clown hi I'm Natasha
I've been a clown for six years and
these are my horror stories in high
school I helped with this community
theater day camp and it was like a
week-long and every day we had these
little kids the last day out it's got to
come in and be a clown and it was gonna
be laughter and so much fun and I had
this little girl for your little girl he
was like one of my favorites it took
place in the basement of a church so
we're sitting in the basement of a
church I'm holding this little as a
clown putting this little girl on my lap
and I'm making her laugh and then she
laughed so hard she peed herself and
then she peed on me and then she like
got up and ran away so everybody's like
why is she like running away from the
clown I tried to let go after her I
didn't want to make a scene and she was
so embarrassed and she just like ran off
and but it was this moment of like I'm
sorry little girl I'm so sorry
so I made a little girl pee on herself
at a church basement she didn't she was
laughing so hard but I feel sad and I
hope I didn't destroy her feelings about
clowns I hope I didn't make her afraid
of clowns forever so I'm lucky enough to
work on a lot of TV shows as a clown and
recently I was at a major studio which
will remain unnamed they were running
very late and they were trying to shoot
four shows in one day and it was the
last day of production and I was hired
as a clown to be in a giant sequence
with 20 kids in a mansion with five
clowns and the kids go crazy and cause
chaos and ruin a birthday party and one
of the kids accidentally pushes a clown
on stilts and that clown falls over and
chaos and hilarity ensued but they
didn't have time for rehearsal because
they were running very late they had a
stunt double working as a lady clown
metal steel stilts and they said action
and she lists her mark and almost killed
a child except Johnny the clown grabbed
the kid pulled the kid out of the way
she landed the stunt coordinator comes
over to me and says thank you for saving
a kid for the next take can you look out
for all the kids okay I'm here to be a
clown but I'll watch out for the kids
take to the stunt lady in the steel
stilts misses her mark again and instead
of almost killing the kid knocks me in
the head with her steel stilts I still
had about 40 seconds of clown stuff with
kids attacking me and I finished the
take and when it was over the first
assistant director ran over the first
thing he said is ah you're fine that was
no big deal
and I took his hand and I put it under
this wig and I let him touch the
contusion that was already the size of
half of a boiled egg they got what they
wanted but it wasn't a great take I did
what they wanted
I finished the tape and I got a bump in
the head in a scar forever as a special
memory
gosh it's fun to be working in Hollywood
every lady clown has a dad story you at
a kid's birthday party
you know nice house walk in you know
kids nice you know we're doing good and
then there was dad I've done parties
before where the dads are a little
friendly but this dad had definitely
been drinking his wife was there and his
daughter questioned the party Ford and
dad started it was kind of like the
shoulder like the arm grabbed a little
bit you know I was wearing a red nose
the time and then he's like I want to
honk your nose honk honk honk and I was
like no you're not so I took it off he
kept doing it
they had a food truck so I come in the
house like back kitchen area and he
comes in by himself and it's just me and
him in this room and I'm late your
daughter's birthday and your wife is
here and clearly you've had too
many brewskis so I just got my stuff and
left like I didn't finish the party I
just the clown clowns out sorry little
girl don't honk my nose don't be a drunk
dad and respect the lady clowns just
respect the ladies I audition all the
time as a clown in all the years I've
been a clown I have never once booked as
a scary clown and I do have a great
headshot that you can see of me as a
scary clown but you know who always gets
those jobs great big giant men who are
not clowns they show up they put them in
ridiculous outfits with crazy clown
makeup and here's how they do it they
put a regular makeup on and then they
just start making their makeup smeared
and I come in and I got a great look and
I'm all like girl I'm a scary clown you
shut up and they get the booking and I
don't
so my horror story ends with the fact
that I've never once worked as a horror
clown because I'm just too delightful
what can you do being a clown is tough
and it's a lot tougher than people think
and we just want to come and bring joy
and just bring a party you know and
celebrate don't be like let us do our
job please for people to don't be scared
of clowns we're out there just to make
you laugh if you want a scary clown go
see a scary movie but when you see a
regular clown don't scream don't run
away we just want to make you laugh
that's what we're here for
I swear we're not trying to be scary
clowns are scary and you should watch
out for scary clown
because when a scary clown comes to get
you in your mind and your nightmare
there's nothing you're gonna be able to
do to get that clown out nightmares or
maybe you just go to a party and there's
a guy making balloons but have fun gosh
darn yeah look I got all dressed up for
you you think I wake up like this
[Music]